hello everyone and welcome to the
mindscape podcast i'm your host sean
carroll and you know sometimes i'm
amazed that society works at all
it's the ultimate emergent phenomenon
right we have all these agents all these
individual people they have their own
agendas they have their own desires
motivations they have their own
capacities and abilities right and
somehow they come together to form a
society now sometimes the society is a
little bit more well ordered than others
but it generally happens this sort of
organization
sometimes it's top-down there's an
autocratic dictatorship
increasingly in the modern world it is
bottom-up people actually get to vote
for who leads us but inevitably there
will be some flaws in the system right
there will be individuals who are not
necessarily civic-minded who
nevertheless get a lot of power right
they're not in it for the greater good
they're in it for their own good but
either we elect them or they seize power
somehow this is a problem this is a
problem for how society works it's a
very broad problem a specific aspect of
it is the idea of corruption the idea
that once people get into positions of
power they do things to benefit
themselves rather than working for the
good of society so what is this
corruption how do we think about it and
how do we get rid of it does power
corrupt in other words if we take
perfectly decent people and put them in
positions of power do they automatically
become corrupt or are people who are
corruptable those who want to seek power
and therefore use it to their own
advantages today's guest is brian kloss
who is an associate professor in global
politics at university college london
he's also a columnist for the washington
post and he has his own podcast the
power corrupts podcast appropriately
enough and his new book is called
corruptable who gets power and how it
changes us he studied exactly this
question of if you take a whole bunch of
people give them power do they all
become more corrupt or are there ways
that corruptable people are able to
seize power for their own pernicious
agendas interestingly
brian does actually offer some solutions
there are some things you can do as a
society some easy things some things
that would be harder to implement but
some things you can do to make it less
likely that people who get into power
become corrupted once they're there it's
very very important because you know as
we mentioned before on the podcast we're
in this gigantic phase of social history
where gigantic in the sense that the
structures that we're dealing with are
gigantic corporations institutions
nations pan-national organizations it's
very very hard for individuals
to make an impact and therefore we need
to work harder to make sure that these
institutions are not corrupt at least to
the extent that we can it's a worthy
challenge to take up and brian's book is
a good start for it so let's go
[Music]
brian kloss welcome to the mindscape
podcast
thanks for having me it's great to be
here
i guess it's kind of interesting because
it took me a little bit not hopefully
not too long but a little bit to figure
out the angle of the book that you've
written because we've had a lot of books
a lot of chit chat on
populism authoritarianism right you know
strong
person rule and the decline of democracy
but you have a slightly different angle
of corruption and corruptability so
what's the relationship there i mean how
should we think about
corruption i kind of it kind of conjures
up visions of you know uh old school big
city machine politics and taking some
bribes to get someone you know their
potholes fixed or something like that
yeah you know i'm trying to really
understand uh power and also why
powerful people are so often corruptable
people uh and i use the term corruptable
rather than corrupt because
it's it's getting this idea of are they
changing their behavior as a result of
the power um
there's the very famous quote of power
tends to corrupt you know power tends to
corrupt absolute power corrupts
absolutely by lord acton
and it's one of those things where you
know that's true it is uh all the
psychology research shows that power
does corrupt but i wanted to understand
many of the underlying dynamics because
the real story is much more complicated
much more interesting than that tagline
would suggest and so what i'm trying to
understand is why do certain people seek
power why do corruptable people seem to
seek power more than others why does
power change people
and how can we fix it how does the
system that we have around individuals
change the way that they behave once
they're in power and should we think
about the corruption as specifically
using this powerful position to enrich
yourself or is it just sort of more a
disconnect between your job and what you
actually do
yeah so in in political science
literature corruption usually refers to
using some sort of public office for
personal gain private gain uh and that's
usually financial but it can be involved
with nepotism and payoffs for you know
lucrative jobs for family members etc
yeah
i'm thinking about corruptability in a
broader sense by which i basically mean
i mean you know
you use precise terms as an academic but
i'm basically talking about powerful
people doing bad things okay um you know
harming other individuals uh abusing
them
sometimes it involves embezzlement and
stealing sometimes it's you know police
officers who are
uh doing things that they shouldn't be
doing sometimes it's ceos who are um you
know terrorizing their employees and
making them live in a culture of fear so
i'm looking at a sort of lens around
power and trying to understand why it's
so often the case that as we look up in
society we're often disappointed and one
of the sort of paradoxes that i i tend
to
find is i've interviewed some really
awful people right i i did more than 500
interviews for this book
war criminals corrupt kingpins all sorts
of people uh cult leaders you name it
and yet i really believe in human nature
i believe that most people are pretty
good and so the paradox is you know
whenever i talk to people they say
things like
all of my friends and family are like
good normal decent people why is it
that like when i look to society in
terms of the highest echelons of who we
choose to put in charge of us that seems
to not be the case and and that's where
i'm trying to sort of argue that the
systems we've designed have
rolled out the red carpet to people who
probably shouldn't be in power
i guess from the point of view here in
the us uh where you're from but you're
in the uk right now um i think that
there's a feeling i'm not going to say
how accurate it is but on the republican
side there's a lot of corrupt people on
the democratic side there's a lot of
ineffectual people so i think maybe on
the your next book should be called
ineffectual how how we keep
electing people to office who'd never
get anything done
yeah i mean you know i think i don't and
i don't think that the the parties i
mean i agree with that assessment in
general about what's going on at the
moment but i don't think that there's
any sort of uh partisan
aspect to the book in the sense that
i think this is a human problem you know
there's there's been people who've been
debating these questions for a very long
time about why does it seem
that those who get power who drink at
its trough are so often
not the best among us um and and i think
you can take a specific snapshot in time
in any society and obviously the
pendulum has swung one way or another
and the u.s is quite an extreme example
where i think the system is is really
badly broken
and one of the big arguments i make in
the book is that you know this matters
enormously because rotten systems
attract rotten people and good systems
attract good people i mean
one of my um favorite studies from
economists that have done this in in the
book that i mentioned is a study of dice
dice rolls and corruption in various
places where what they do is they take
these students and they say you know
roll a dice 42 times and self-report
your score and the more time you get
sixes the more time uh we're gonna give
the more money we're gonna give you so
you can lie on your on your self
reporting and this was by design and
then what they did is they used
statistical methods to figure out how
often people had lied uh to infer based
on you know statistical regularities
and they surveyed the students and said
what do you want to do with your career
and when they did the study in india
where the civil service was notoriously
corrupt and had lots of graft and
bribery the students who lied on their
dice rolls really wanted to be civil
servants when they did the same study in
denmark
the whole dynamic was inverted all the
really honest students wanted to be
civil servants and all the really uh you
know dishonest students wanted to go
into business and make money so you know
it's one of these very obvious
statements that actually i think is not
appreciated enough because we tend to
think of powerful people either as good
or bad
and what a lot of the book is talking
about is how much the systems
mediate this effect and that's actually
quite hopeful
because you can change systems much more
easily than you can change people no i
love that emphasis of it it's a very
good lesson it's almost one of those
things where i have to be careful
because i want that to be true so you
know we need to be careful that we're
not tricking ourselves into it but um
let me just let me just you said it out
loud and we'll get into details about it
but let's just home in on the power
corrupting thing because you said yes
indeed it is true that power corrupts so
where does the evidence come for that
how do you tease out the difference
between
being in power corrupts you versus the
corrupt people
seize power
yeah this is the the chicken or the egg
problem for the for the book is you know
is it that corruptable people seek power
or does power corrupt the evidence is
very strong that both happen that
corruptable people gravitate towards
power much more than the average person
and that power does change you so the
evidence comes a few ways one is just in
psychology research where what they do
is you know i think frankly these are
somewhat flimsy recreations of power
they're forced to do because they can't
actually make people ceos and they can't
actually make people presidents and so
on um but when they do studies pretty
much all of them show that there is a
psychological change in how they view
people below them as abstractions they
start to think of them as more
disposable they have this mechanism
called illusory control where they
believe that they can manipulate
outcomes more than they actually can
there's also just basic stuff that makes
a lot of intuitive sense i mean i talked
to
andrew yang the former presidential
candidate on the democratic side at one
point and the point he made which is
very straightforward is he says for a
year i walked into a room everybody
stood on their feet and cheered for me
every joke i told even if it was a
terrible joke they laughed uproariously
you know you start to change your
thought pattern and neuroscientists have
looked at looked at this and found
evidence of actual brain changes um the
the best example this is in non-human
primates because it's easier to study
and dissect and so on but when you look
at macaque monkeys i interviewed a uh
a researcher out at wake forest who has
a class 2 drug license for peer-cut
cocaine and what he does
is he takes these macaques and puts them
in non-house situations where they're an
individual housing unit so they don't
have any hierarchy and then he basically
lifts up the barriers so all of a sudden
they're in a group of four and they very
quickly set up a dominance hierarchy one
two three four
then he puts them in this chair that
they've been trained to use where one
lever releases banana pellets and the
other lever intravenously gives them
cocaine
and what's fascinating about this is the
dominant monkeys at the top of the
hierarchy all choose the banana pellets
and the submissive monkeys all choose
the cocaine and when they re-jigger the
monkeys into a new housing situation and
it happens again the same effect happens
so if you were a dominant monkey in
experiment experiment a and you become a
submissive monkey in experiment b in a
different group
the effect holds and when they actually
look at the brains the dopamine
receptors have changed
they actually have
a fundamental shift in the hierarchy
causing changes to some of the chemical
reactions happening in the brain and i'm
not a neuroscientist to understand
exactly what's going on but the evidence
is quite clear that there are biological
effects and of course with stress this
also uh exists and there's lots of
evidence about how stress ages people in
power and so on so it's not just a
psychological thing it's also a
biological thing which i think is
important to understand i mean maybe
i'm not sure if this is
grounded in evidence or pure speculation
but i'm not sure i understand the
mechanism behind the submissive monkeys
taking the cocaine is it that they're
not getting getting dopamine from power
like they're not drunk on power
therefore they need to get high from
cocaine whereas the powerful monkeys are
happy with banana pellets because that
doesn't quite seem to
match with my experience of human
powerful people
it's it's the idea of uh self-medicating
that's what their hypothesis is anyway
that they say that effectively it's it's
a stressful and uh difficult place to be
in a hierarchy especially in non-human
primates that is stripped of lots of
other forms of meaning that we would
have in human society i mean one of the
virtues of humans is that we have
intersecting forms of hierarchies so you
can be a powerless person who's low on
the pecking order in your corporate
world and yet in your family or in your
softball team or whatever you can feel
valued and so the idea here is because
you don't have the norms and cultures
around society that it's such a singular
bad thing to happen to you as a macaque
to be at the bottom that it's quite
stressful and actually one of the things
that's that's interesting is it's not
just the cocaine study the um
the the the research that's been done on
baboon hierarchies is really really
interesting on this on this front
because
what they show is that you have you can
measure sort of biological aging and
they use this
process that again you know i'm not the
expert on it but it's called dna
methylation where they're using
effectively markers in in you know in
genetic code to look at biological
levels of aging and it's different from
the clock right so you can age faster
than the calendar
and what they found is that as you go
down to the bottom it's the most
stressful because you don't have access
to resources mates food you're being
picked on all the time so you age faster
as you go up you age a little bit slower
and then when you get to the apex when
you get to the alpha male you age a lot
and the reason for that is because
you've got a target on your back so all
the other baboons are going for you all
the time
and so it's this acute level of stress
and it leads to this somewhat
counterintuitive conclusion which
actually the the beta baboon is actually
the the best it's the one that doesn't
have the stress but it has the resources
it's sort of you know human terms would
be like it's not good to be the king but
it's good to be in the court uh so to
speak and again this is something it's
biological it's a question about aging
it's a question about stress levels uh
there's a lot of evidence in the human
world as well but these ones are
interesting because they strip away
the sort of complexity of modern you
know
culture and so on and show there is
actually a biological effect tied to
hierarchy yeah and it's not surprising
but i i like the uh the turnover effect
there that you you age more uh when
you're at the very top but people still
want it uh okay so we're gonna get to
that let me i love the uh
experiments and primates and what we
learned from that but let's go back in
history a little bit and talk about
human beings because this has been hot
in the news like i guess in the news in
certain circles with uh the new book out
by david graber and david wengrow was it
um claiming that we were all anarchists
back in the day or you know we could
still be and uh there's a that's in
conflict with the standard story where i
guess there was no hierarchy and then
agriculture came along and that that
gave us uh the impetus to become more
hierarchical uh what is your take on the
origins of the existence of hierarchy in
the first place
yeah so chapter two of the book's called
the evolution of power and it touches on
this idea and i think you know
what is what is clear to me is that the
story that's been told for a very long
time which i i detail in the book and i
explain it the one of what's called
reverse dominance hierarchies where you
had deliberate efforts to try to tear
people down if they tried to seize power
in hunter-gatherer societies and you had
more egalitarianism among small bands of
people up to 80 people mostly
i i think that that broadly the the gist
of that is true in some pockets
and is probably oversimplified in other
places i mean there's some evidence for
example
uh that's often talked about in the
standard story that one of the arguments
for this is agriculture creating larger
societies and then hierarchy emerges
i refer to these various hypotheses
somewhat pitifully in the book as the
war and peace hypothesis ps being
p-e-a-s right so it's either conflict
causing aggregation of hierarchies from
conquest where societies are getting
bigger and becoming hierarchical or ps
one of the early crops that's then used
okay to build larger societies and
create hierarchy and sort of war mps
works works nicely but you know i also
cite in the chapter that there's
evidence from a
guy at harvard named manvir singh who
said look this predicates this argument
is predicated on the idea that you
couldn't have had sedentary lifestyles
in the hunter-gatherer period what about
all the fishing communities i mean they
were sedentary because they were getting
their food from fish so they weren't
moving around the same way and there is
evidence that there was more hierarchy
there so i think it's you know it's
overly simplistic to suggest that we
didn't have hierarchy in the human past
and yet i also think that something is
fundamentally different about the way we
live now and in these extremely
hierarchical societies where you're
constantly reminded where you are in in
status
every single thing you do one of the
more interesting bits of research i read
in researching the uh this section
because you know i'm a political
scientist so i don't always read
evolutionary biology text but i love
this research also came out of harvard
where they're looking at
why humans are uniquely able to throw
objects with extreme speed and accuracy
and the sort of evolution of our our
shoulders and how that's affected the
development of the species and and
effectively the way the story goes is
that
it be because we're able to effectively
kill
other humans at a distance
we have severed the link with ranged
weapons between size and dominance which
is not true
in many non-human primate species where
you know to kill a male chimpanzee you
better be big right uh whereas in in
human society i looked this up it's one
of the most depressing statistics i've
seen but about three people are shot by
toddlers in the united states every week
and so you know we have found a way to
make it so even babies effectively can
uh kill adult male humans and that has
had profound effects on the way you
determine who's in charge because it no
longer has to be the physically largest
or one of the physically largest males
of the species but i guess i'm confused
because you've already alluded to the
fact that primates have very pronounced
dominance hierarchies
i guess i'm skeptical that we were ever
hierarchy less
it seems to be
and i'm completely ignorant about this
so i could be completely wrong but it
seems to me that once the size of the
community gets beyond a handful
um we tend to have leaders and followers
even a group of friends we have leaders
and followers so are we are we glossing
over some of the differences that were
always there
yeah it's possible the the standard
story the one that's being challenged
more recently uh points to this this
sort of separation between us and
non-human primates using ranged weapons
and also talking about how most humans
were in small bands of 80 people this
doesn't mean there weren't leaders that
emerged in some facets of life i mean if
you're good at something it's pretty
nonsensical to believe that you didn't
have some sort of clout within your
community for being good at something
but there's some interesting evidence
this is often uh trotted out by by the
anthropologists who make this argument
uh of the kung community which is one of
the modern day hunter-gatherer
communities and they have this ingenious
system that i think you know really
speaks to this uh reverse dominance
hierarchy in which you try to ensure
egalitarianism against the people who
try to seize power so the way they
figure out how to do this is they think
look in a hunter-gatherer society if
you're good at hunting you're going to
become the powerful figure because
you're providing for the community so
instead what we're going to do is we're
going to sort of create a communal
ownership of the arrowheads that are
used in hunting and we're going to
rotate them regularly and the credit for
the kill doesn't go to the person who
actually killed the animal it goes to
the person who owned the arrowhead which
we swap around the community at regular
intervals and that ensures basically
through randomization
that nobody ever gets too much credit
for being a hunter and in fact the
anthropologists who have uh talked to
these modern day communities or 1960s
research a lot of this was
they have this
amazing ritual called insulting the meat
in which when the hunter comes back with
a great kill they basically make fun of
it and say how could you come back with
something that's so tiny like why did
you fail so badly and it's a ritual to
ensure that the hunter doesn't emerge as
someone who's too big for their britches
so to speak so you know
again one of the things that i i do in
the book is i say
some of this stuff is unfalsifiable
right i mean we can't go back
evolutionary anthropology most of it is
unfalsifiable because we can't interview
people from 50 000 years ago and ask
them what they're thinking
i think what is clear and i think this
is worth pointing out in in the research
on hierarchies is that
the evolution of our brains
has not proceeded to pace with the
evolution of our societies in other
words the time scales of 50 000 years or
whatever um for us from the stone age
hunter-gatherers are not sufficient to
say that our brain structure has changed
dramatically but our lifestyle has
changed profoundly and so there i do buy
into the hypothesis of what's called the
evolutionary mismatch that says
some of the templates that are in our
brains for leadership selection might
have been adaptive for a very very
different time but again i have a
footnote in the book that says
we can't falsify this we can't say for
sure it makes sense but there's no way
to prove it and i think that's you know
that's why i have a healthy dose of
skepticism about some of the sweeping
claims that come from this world of
research yeah no i'm very happy to
entertain these hypotheses and let them
uh inspire us but like you say healthy
skepticism makes sense because the data
are not enough to really constrain
things i did i did want to ask one
little follow-up on that wonderful
reverse dominance hierarchy thing
because even though it's an amazing
story i love it but it's also clearly a
sophisticated intentional response to
people trying to get too much power
right if people trying to become overly
powerful so it's clearly a mechanism
that is responding to something that
already existed
no i i don't think that the evolutionary
anthropologists are arguing that that
humans didn't ever have power seeking i
think the idea is that some societies
that were smaller that had more communal
living of 80 people which is a you know
a threshold that is manageable to
imagine you know the idea you know
everyone right if you start to abuse
them there's going to they say look
there are people who try to seize power
even in the uncontacted tribes that then
become uh part of the world of of trying
to infer the past uh which you know it's
a flawed research technique but it's all
there is really um
what they say is yeah there's there's
people who try to seize power all the
time they're often the personality types
that we would recognize in modern
society some of them are are shamanic
leaders or they claim some sort of
divine uh power legitimacy some of them
are warriors who do particularly well
and then say i should be in charge
the reverse dominance hierarchy is
saying that there had to be a deliberate
systemic mechanism to counteract this
and
the reason i'm somewhat skeptical that
this was always the case is because
surely it failed sometimes right i mean
surely there is the person who would
have emerged as a leader and that's why
i think the evidence is probably at best
a bit mixed about this
i i do think that there is something as
i said before profoundly different about
how they lived and also the size of the
group does make a lot of sense that it
would have a different function of
hierarchy because you know one of the
aspects of modern living is that you
don't know the people you're ruling over
right i mean you know it's just
they're people you're never going to
interact with and that is
strikingly different from how humans
live for much of the history of the
species
okay so once we start having these uh
formalized power structures and
hierarchies i mean we can easily
distinguish between two different ways
in which people might get power one that
they seize it because they're the
biggest or the best and the other is
that they are granted it by you know
some communal agreement uh are both of
these common in the ancient world or was
there a one that is almost always the
case
well it's it's hard to know again
because we don't we don't have you know
they don't leave traces um so we in the
sort of prehistoric periods we don't
have good evidence of how somebody may
have emerged and there are there are to
be fair uh some exceptions as i say to
uh
to this sort of egalitarian hypothesis
that are worth considering because some
burial sites around the world do show
evidence of hierarchy where you have uh
you know effectively what might have
been a local leader or prince or
something like that buried with much
more uh than the average person whereas
other places this is one of the pieces
of evidence the egalitarians point to
it's completely equal right there's just
sort of every but but that might also be
because they were all poor and they
didn't have any sort of you know so one
way so we can't say with certainty uh
one way or or another what we can say is
that the way that we see this in the
modern world is uh we focus a lot on the
people who gain power as
being morally condemned and we very
rarely turn the mirror back on ourselves
and say why did we give somebody so
unfit power
and i think that's something that i try
to talk about more in the book of why
we're seduced by certain things why we
have cognitive biases that cause us to
make irrational judgments about leaders
and how actually
you're totally right to point to the
fact that there's two sides of the coin
and that
the side of the coin that points back to
us the uncomfortable side uh is rarely
interrogated by people who like to
condemn leaders as being fully
responsible right even in democratic
societies where of course were part of
the picture
well let's talk about the kinds of
person who tries to get to power whether
it's through outright seizing it or
being elected or whatever uh we've
already
alluded to this but i think we can go a
little bit deeper now um
are the ones who are either corrupt or
obviously corruptable are those the
natural candidates to run for office
roughly speaking
yeah so there's there's a there's a few
things that are happening i mean this is
the the classic self-selection effect
with power right we we often give power
to people who put themselves forward and
say i should be powerful that's what
elections are it's what often uh job
promotions are and so on i tried to
tackle this question and
the conclusion to this spoiler alert was
it's an unsatisfying conclusion because
we can't know for sure but i tried to
tackle the question of whether there's
any sort of genetic basis to this
genetic basis to power seeking which is
an uncomfortable thing to think about
sometimes in humans but it's it's a
reasonable thing to contemplate because
in non-human species you do have
dominance inherited hyenas inherit
dominance zebrafish there's documented
inheritance of dominance and when they
manipulate mice genes they can
manipulate their dominance levels and so
on so it's it's this it would be sort of
odd if genes had nothing to do
uh with power seeking behavior so
researchers have identified what they
call a leadership gene now they've
overclaimed their work i think yeah now
i'm getting a little bit more skeptical
but
yeah so
i i find this
what what they did was was a reasonable
research design they compare fraternal
twins and identical twins in a way of
trying to isolate nature and nurture a
bit and then they try to do surveys to
figure out who ends up in leadership
positions later in life
my problem with the research is that
doesn't actually
cover power seeking it covers power
obtaining and those things are not the
same yeah and so you know to my mind i
said i present this research in the book
i say look there's a correlation that
does exist between this gene and
obtaining leadership later in life the
sample is reasonable it's not too small
so maybe something's happening there but
i can't say whether that gene that
they're finding is just you know
co-varying with other genes that make
you more affable or outgoing or
attractive or you know whatever it is so
i think it's quite weak evidence that
power seeking is necessarily genetic
you know i tried to triangulate this a
bit i interviewed people who were the
offspring of very very powerful people
again it's a flimsy source of evidence
but you know you take what you can get
it's one of the most interesting parts
of the book in a way because i um sat
down with the daughter of john bedell
bokassa who was a cannibalistic dictator
in the central african empire in the
1970s
and she had quite a traumatic childhood
and still sort of reveres her dad uh
even though he fed dissidents to
crocodiles and at one point
allegedly fed a dissident to a visiting
french diplomat so
uh as like as human flesh so you know
not a good guy basically and
and this is a situation where
the aspects of she she
was talking about the idea of returning
to power herself again it's anecdotal
it's not compelling evidence so
we're sort of back at square one because
you can't disentangle nature and nurture
that well and even the genes that we do
find that correlate with leadership
maybe because of other things about
society not about power seeking itself i
think what is reasonable to conclude is
that power hungry people by definition
whether it's genetic or otherwise are
those who gravitate towards power right
that's what we mean when you say power
hungry yeah and
what i often describe this as i say you
know
when i met 500 plus very powerful people
often who did bad things they were there
was a diverse group right i mean there's
different types of people some were
likable some were monsters some were
really callous some were charming the
thing i could say with certainty about
all of them is they were not
representative of the general public
and you know there was they were unusual
they were all unusual people and you
know i often describe this as saying if
you went to a high school basketball
tryout it would be really weird if the
height among the people who are trying
out was average yeah this is exactly the
same with power you you don't have a
self-selection mechanism that's
randomized so people who covet power
put themselves forward and as a result
of that the people who are in positions
of power are almost by definition people
who find power to be an end in itself
disproportionate to the general public
anyway and that itself is a problem
because you you want you know
douglas adams has a series of quotes
about this but he effectively says you
know anybody who can be made president
of the galaxy should on no account be
allowed to do the job and i think
he's pretty much hit on a lot of aspects
of my research in this that the people
who think they should be president
there's probably something a bit wrong
with them right and the people who can
get themselves made president there's
certainly something wrong with them so
it's uh
it's one of those aspects where it's a
very long-winded answer uh and at the
end we're sort of stuck uh we don't have
good evidence that power seeking
behavior is discernibly genetic or
otherwise uh and i know it's
unsatisfying but that's where i think we
are with the evidence no i think both of
these make sense both the fact that uh
power seeking people are
different than non-power seeking people
who could argue with that uh and the
fact that it's hard to figure out
whether it's genetic or not that's also
fine but i am interested in pushing a
little bit on this
potential connection between power
seeking and
corruptability uh you know just like
douglas adams within academia as you
know there's a rule of thumb that any
person who wants to be department chair
should never be allowed to be department
chair right you should force the
reluctant people to do it because
they'll be better at it um and there's
somewhere either in your book or in an
interview you did
that that seems to suggest that
narcissistic psychopaths are over
represented in positions of power so uh
given that people who want to get power
are different in various ways is one of
those ways that they're more likely to
be narcissistic psychopaths
yes so this is this is where we get into
the realm of psychology and i'm not a
psychologist but the the what i do talk
about in the book extensively is this
this concept of the dark triad which is
uh
narcissism machiavellianism and
psychopathy and psychopathy is actually
a clinical diagnosis you know there are
brain differences whereas the others are
are more personality traits but if they
come together in a chemical cocktail
known as the dark triad in high levels
those people are disproportionately
likely to seek power and
disproportionately likely to get power
and this is where the this is where the
i think the the research is not
necessarily pointing to something that's
innate to human nature but is also
mediated through the way we've set up
modern systems what i mean by that is
that a lot of the ways you get power in
modern society are unavoidably
performative in other words your job
interview is a performance your election
campaign is a performance and people who
are narcissistic are highly attuned to
what other people think of them people
who are psychopathic the the two words
that every psychopath expert i talked to
said to me was superficial charm
and and very chameleon-like they they
they're very good at sort of blending
what they think the person wants them to
be with what they become uh and and
machiavellian in terms of just sort of
very strategic thinkers
and the evidence that we have when
they've done observational research
which again you know it's flawed in some
ways there's some aspects where when you
measure psychopathy it depends on what
scale you use etc etc
what they find is depending on the
research you look at is between four and
a hundred times more psychopaths are in
positions of leadership than the general
public and they're rare in the general
public um and i focus on them because i
think it's important to understand that
when they do emerge even though most
leaders are not psychopaths they're
particularly destructive um one of the
really interesting bits of research i
interviewed a neuroscientist who studies
psychopaths and
the way that she sort of put it is that
uh people with the dark triad dialed
really far up on all three traits uh
effectively have and especially
psychopaths have empathy sort of
switched off by default um and what what
she did was she did mri scans fmri scans
where she would show people both
psychopaths and non-psychopaths really
disturbing images of you know children
in distress animals being abused etc
stuff that would make you want to get
out of the mri machine if you were a
normal person
and what she found is that there was a
massive difference right like like the
brains of normal people are lighting up
with anguish and psychopaths have a very
muted response
but then she had this sort of moment of
of uh
you know let's let's just try something
else out so she told the psychopath try
to imagine what it would be like
to feel the pain of these people to
sympathize with them to sympathize with
the animals and all of a sudden the
scans looked remarkably similar to the
normal individuals and so what she was
saying is that it seems to be the case
that psychopaths can
dial up empathy in moments when they
need to persuade people that they're
normal functioning individuals those who
can't do that are called dysfunctional
psychopaths in the psychology and
neuroscience literature around this and
those are the serial killers they can't
turn it off and they just they they're
impossible uh to manage because they
just can never dial their traits down
the functional psychopaths as they're
sometimes called are the ones that the
psychologists argue are in boardrooms
and in in you know in elected office
because they're able to moderate
uh their their traits when they need to
in those moments of performance but i
think you know it's a difficult one as
all this research social research in
general is very difficult or to
disentangle some of these things because
humans are immensely complicated and
you're trying to study something that
first off is where it's being studied
sometimes and secondly is also moderated
through a system that is not necessarily
part of human tendencies but it's
actually just modern culture and you
can't disentangle them uh as much as we
like to uh imagine we can sometimes in
social science yeah and i certainly uh i
get that the psychology aspects are not
your uh professional interest and we'll
get to the systems because i think the
systems are ultimately more important
but boy this psychology is still
fascinating i got to ask i got to dig in
on this this issue of the fact that the
the functional psychopaths anyway have
this aspect of performativity um which
fascinates me because you might naively
think that if you're just a psychopath
you're just sort of uh you don't not
only do not feel empathy but you have
trouble
uh relating to ordinary people or acting
like them or whatever but
you're you're sort of hinting that
there's kind of an opposite aspect that
the psychopath is one who can put on the
right mask and play the right role to
get what they want in a
consciously manipulative way i'm not
sure
yeah i think they are consciously
manipulative and there's also there's
some really interesting research on this
that you know i i think i have like one
sentence in the book that talks about
this it's not a not something i go into
but um you know all of this research i
think has caveats and and flaws because
there's no perfect method of actually
studying this stuff by virtue of the the
subject matter but
especially because psychopaths are
constantly trying to deceive you right i
mean they're they're not saying i'm a
psychopathic narcissist
um but what they have done i found this
study really interesting about how
strategic thinkers
uh that are psychopaths can be very good
at getting power and how psychopaths can
be very rational in times where empathy
might actually be a hindrance uh to to
others so what they're talking about is
this is basically this game in which um
you have let's i think it's 100 yen in
the example but let's say it's a hundred
dollars and you've got a pair of people
in an experiment
and
the first person who's randomly assigned
is the proposer so they propose a split
of the hundred dollars and the acceptor
or rejector is the other person who can
either accept or reject the offer if
they reject the offer both players leave
with no money if they accept the offer
they both get however much has been
proposed so there's sort of a it's sort
of a game theory you know dynamic
and what they found is that most normal
people hit their breaking point about 70
30. yeah so if you get above that the
average person starts to say you know
screw you to the other person i'm not
going to let you take any money i'm
going to lose
you know it's an 80 20 split you
proposed i'm going to be 20 poorer but
at least you're not going to get 80
and they have this thing called skin
conductance response where they also
were were measuring things on the skin
uh the electricity on the skin effect
again this this is beyond my pay grade
in terms of political science but uh but
skin conductors response so they had
electrical uh you know
they're measuring like uh how the skin
reacted in these situations and how much
it was sort of affecting you
and what they found is that the
psychopaths would basically accept
almost anything and that their type of
response
um and they did this again i think in
fmri machines the type of response was
different it was it was not a a sort of
response that was about
um
any sort of thing about justice it was
more of a response to do with anger
at the person but anger that didn't
cause them to reject the offer
so there was both a qualitative
difference in sort of how the person
perceived the interaction but also in
terms of the actual behavior uh they
didn't hit a breaking point they just
say i'll take the five dollars because
it's better for me um
and and so the suggestion that the
psychologists have have grafted onto
this research is that perhaps this helps
psychopaths rise through the corporate
ladder a bit um because they will do
things that are objectively in their
self-interest when other people would
say i can't possibly live with this
because it's not fair um
so you know whether we can take one
small study
and infer that this is how society works
i don't know but i i i do suggest that
there are fundamental differences in how
these people behave and you know i find
the
psychopathy research somewhat more
persuasive because
there are both clinical diagnoses and
aspects of
brain functioning that are
objectively different under
circumstances whereas some of the
psychology trait research i think
sometimes ends up being a bit more
wishy-washy we did a podcast with
herbert gintus the economist and he
mentioned um this kind of game theory
studies and apparently
exactly like you said except that there
can be pretty wild cultural differences
from place to place i mean there are
some
minority of cultures that people get
insulted if you try to give them any
money at all in this split they think
they're being condescended to but uh i i
like the idea that psychopaths are just
really good utilitarians and will take
the whatever money that they're offered
well it's it's great that you mentioned
that though because this is one of the
areas again where you know i i mention
this in the book at length where i talk
about the the deficits in psychology
research related to the samples they
have and of course with the replication
crisis and all these other things they
have been hyper aware now that they're
over representing basically
affluent white college students at ivy
league universities when they claim to
be explaining humans
which is a pretty big problem right
especially because they're also in 2020
or 2021 or whatever it is
the psychopath research is the same sort
of thing i asked lots of the psychopath
experts who said
like is a chinese psychopath different
from an american psychopath and like we
don't have
good enough data on this there's some
there's some initial
studies that are being conducted this
way but a lot of the focus is on western
psychopaths and it's it's
crucial i think to understand this
because
it disentangles the aspects of what's
actually happening on the the
neurological level from the cultural
level and i don't know the answer to
that i wish i had better information
because i wanted i think in a way it
would have actually strengthened some of
my arguments to say that the interaction
between even a psychopath where there's
something like objectively wrong about
their brain can be mediated by a culture
right that would be quite a profound
insight because one of the quite
uncomfortable things with psychopathy
research is that a lot of the criminal
justice systems that find the
dysfunctional psychopaths effectively
write them off and say you can't be
paroled because there's nothing to fix
you rehabilitation for a psychopath
isn't deemed to be something that's
attainable um it's but for for my work
it's more interesting in the sense of
what's the diagnostic tool to fix the
problem because if somebody's a
psychopath changing the system to try to
remind them of the sort of
responsibilities they have just to
others is totally ineffectual it might
work for some other people shame might
work for some other people it's not
going to work for a psychopath uh so you
know i think this question of like is
power changing someone
yeah i think it is
but i don't think it's changing
psychopaths the same way it's changing
everybody else and so one of the
arguments i'm making is accurate
diagnostics of understanding why a bad
outcome is occurring from someone in
power is crucial to fixing it sometimes
it's the system sometimes it's the
individual sometimes it's you know
their chemistry is out of whack in their
brain whatever it is but
understanding that is the first step to
fixing it and you if you apply the wrong
tool
uh
to to a certain problem you're gonna
actually make it worse probably so it's
it's really really crucial that we don't
just say power corrupts absolute power
corrupts absolutely and move on well and
it's probably also crucial to say that
not every person who seeks higher office
is a psychopath right are there are
there people who most are not are there
people who are not just non-psychopaths
but
actually
have higher motivations i mean tell me
those people exist please
they absolutely do and the reason you
know it's funny because
i think when you read my book you can
get a bit of a sense that i think that
all leaders are awful people and i don't
think that i think there's many many
many uh wonderful leaders in fact the
way that i got into politics was my mom
ran for school board when i was eight
years old and she just wanted to serve
the community yeah um but you know i i
think this is where even on this example
um it's it's the systems because we
talked earlier about modern republican
politics and modern american politics
the people who run for school board now
are facing death threats harassment of
their children people posting their
addresses online you know my mom didn't
have to weigh up
uh serving the community versus like
immense personal costs and risks to
safety uh she had to deal with like you
know a pay dispute or one
parent who was upset that there wasn't
creationism taught you know and like
it's a totally different different world
but
the point that i i try to stress in the
book is that there's lots and lots of
wonderful people who want to lead i just
think we've made a lot of systems in the
modern world that have made it so the
people who accept the burdens and costs
of those leadership positions
particularly the publicly
scrutinized ones are the ones who are
most likely to find power itself a
reward because it's worth it everybody
else who thinks i want to serve is just
going to bow out and do something else
with their time and the most extreme
example this that i i've come across in
my research i've done a lot of field
work in far-flung places around the
world and in thailand i've met lots of
people who are you know young up and
coming talented people some of them
former students some of them people i've
met in in field research in bangkok
and they all say the same thing like why
would i go into politics because that's
where you lose all your money you end up
in exile or you die because the military
is going to take over power every so
often and when you're on the wrong side
of that coup
everything falls apart for you if i go
into a business where i sell auto parts
i will make money and my life will be
fine and so you have a real
self-selection effect out of politics in
places where it's dangerous and in those
places you know this is one of the
angles that i also have done in my own
research
in sub-saharan africa i crunched the
numbers from
1960 to 2010
the heads of state that lost power in
that period
43 of them were jailed exiled or killed
and you think about what are the
incentives for someone who thinks if i
lose power
these horrible things will happen to me
well this is why you rig elections right
and also who goes into those positions
who thinks like okay yeah it's a coin
flip whether i end up with this horrible
thing happened to me that possibly ends
my life or ruins my life
but i can get away with it because i'm
smarter well i mean there's a
self-selection effect for someone who
thinks they can outfox the system
you know it's something where
there are lots and lots of good people
but the systems we've designed i think
have
disproportionately push those people out
of leadership positions yeah this is
sort of weirdly the optimistic part of
your book right because i mean as you as
you said before it might be hard to
change people's innate humanity or their
uh predilections but we set up these
systems and it seems to be strongly the
case that some systems just allow
corruption to flourish and some
go against it i mean i can't resist uh
asking you to tell the new york city uh
parking ticket story for the u.n
diplomats because i'm sure that many
people have heard it but it's just such
a perfect natural experiment
it is yeah it's it's one of these sort
of great moments where a researcher has
just stumbled upon something that's
quite elegant um so so basically you
know
in the late 1990s into the early 2000s
uh diplomats at the united nations had
diplomatic immunity from at least minor
crimes and this meant they didn't have
to pay parking tickets and quite
astoundingly this meant that there were
150 000 parking tickets to the tune of
18 million dollars racked up by various
un uh officials who had diplomatic
immunity
in 2002 i believe it was mike bloomberg
who was mayor at the time said enough is
enough i'm gonna start impounding the
cars i can't prosecute you or make you
pay the money but i can take your car
away so it's basically a pre and post
accountability
natural experiment the wild west of you
know lack of accountability and then all
of a sudden the risk of real
consequences and what they found was
that in the pre-enforcement period
all of the sort of non-corrupt countries
diplomats part pretty much
normally legally
and all of the corrupt countries
diplomats parked illegally a lot i mean
some of the countries it was hilarious
reading this because it's like
196 parking tickets per diplomat
i believe was the case for either egypt
or yemen or something like that and
almost overnight the enforcement made it
so the egyptians started parking like
the norwegians but the little wrinkle
that i love in this was that if you then
put in the time that the person was in
new york in the pre-enforcement period
the norwegians got worse over time so
the more they could get away with it
the more they started parking illegally
and i the thing that's so elegant about
this is just a perfect encapsulation of
how culture is crucial to understanding
corrupt abusive behavior but also how
accountability and the sort of second
guessing that comes with enforcement uh
can shift behavior over time and it's
it's why you know
having sat down with lots of really
really awful people i posed a question
early on in the book where i sort of
asked people to imagine
being thrust into the role of the
dictator of turkmenistan and you know i
like to think that i would not behave in
an awful way if i was in that role but i
also as a political scientist who
studies these systems i know that if you
don't make the military happy they might
kill your family yeah and so
you know i
i have this line that i think captures
most of my views about social research
which is very simple one of three words
that says people are complicated and
there's a lot of behavior that we chalk
up in sort of popular imagination of
discussions of leaders to their good or
their bad that's actually much more
systemic and situational
than we give it credit for which as you
say is optimistic because it is the
lever we have to make society better
well and what i love about the
uh new york city example is that there's
sort of two things going on on the one
hand the local conditions from which the
diplomats came
clearly mattered right diplomats from
norway acted different it's not simply
where you are in new york city that the
rules uh matter um but then when when
enforcement kicks in you change so
quickly uh it wasn't the behavior wasn't
very sticky it wasn't deeply ingrained
in themselves it was just kind of all
right this is what i do but in different
circumstances i'll act very differently
that there there is the germ of an
optimistic message there
well you know the other the other
example that's exactly on this point
that i've
what i found maddening in writing this
book was that i think there's a lot of
pretty simple interventions that can
make a difference they're not silver
bullets we're never going to fix this
problem but we can really blunt the
effect of it and the the my favorite i
think bit of research i did was on
police actually it's a hot button topic
in the united states uh police reform
and
i i kept getting so annoyed when i was
watching the coverage and discussion of
police reform in the u.s because there's
this huge area that's just not discussed
you know almost everything
the way i put it is almost everything in
the in the police discussion is about
what the police do
and very very little is about who the
police are
and so i started to study recruitment
methods across different cultures for
policing
and you know there's i cherry-picked
this one example because i think it's
just so unbelievably over the top that
this exists but uh there's a case in
doraville georgia a town of 10 000
people outside of atlanta where the
recruitment video that was on the
website flashes the punisher logo to
start which is already a bad start
because it's like the vigilante tortures
he was not a law-abiding citizen
yeah uh and
and then it shows these guys in military
fatigues driving around in a swat tank
like a literal tank
throwing smoke grenades out of it and uh
the the music is die mother eff or die
uh
by dope this heavy metal band and it's
like this like 30 second clip and then
it's like you know join the police
basically right
and i i sat there and i was like
who would respond to this ad right i'd
be like who is going to apply for this
policy net and you see that there's a
lot of research i detail this in the
book in more in more depth but that
talks about militarization of police and
how it's also affected the culture of
departments and so on and my favorite
example to decide but i love this is
like i think it's called boone township
and indiana has one small pond in the
entire area and they have an amphibious
assault vehicle it's like from like from
like iraq you know
you never know so then what do you say
you never know brian i mean there could
be an amphibious assault
well it's one farmhouse is pond so if
that place gets attacked they have the
they have the right tool constant
vigilance but new zealand new zealand
did something totally different they i i
talked to the head of human resources
for the what they call like the vice
president for people you know it's this
nice like corporate speak thing because
new zealand has a national police force
and they recruit nationally so they
spent like millions of dollars on this
recruitment scheme called do you care
enough to be a cop so already we're not
in the punisher territory right and they
have this video it's one of the most
viral videos in new zealand uh it's been
viewed by millions of people in a place
where there's only five million people
and it's this funny recruitment video of
these
very diverse demographically
representative police officers chasing
this unseen suspect and they stop to
dance with people they help an old man
cross the road and then at the end they
catch the suspect and it's a border
collie that's stolen a purse
and then it says do you care enough to
be a cop right and they did this other
like experiment where they have this
emaciated looking hungry boy the the
video is called hungryboy and they have
these hidden cameras and some people
stop to help him and some people just
walk by him and then it just says do you
care enough to be a cop and it's saying
you know the inference is obviously if
you stopped you should be in the police
force and you know
the the demographics of their
applicants changed radically like they
got massive differences both in the
numbers of applicants the personality
traits when they did screening and also
the diversity of the applicants and the
policing relations have improved in new
zealand with the indigenous community
the maori community and the thing that i
just i kept thinking to myself like
this is so easy like this is not a thing
that you have to really think about it's
just the way you depict power in this
instance is obviously going to affect
who thinks i have a place there and so
the way i've always described this is
like so many systems are on autopilot
and we all complain like oh why is it
that all these people are corrupt why do
the police abuse people sometimes you
know it's like we don't do anything
about it right it's just like
it's it's it's something where it
doesn't take you know a quantum
physicist to to figure out the the
answers to some of these issues but you
have to actually try uh and and i think
that is sometimes missing which is
again it's the low-hanging fruit of a
lot of these systems that could actually
be reformed with small changes that add
up to big effects yeah i know i think
this and this is good because it's
pointing out that if we want to fight
corruption or tweak the system to make
it less
uh commonplace
there's sort of an obvious set of things
and i think we will talk about them in a
second about
uh
surveillance or you know keeping track
that you make make it hard for people to
be corrupt but like you say there's also
the thing like trying not to get corrupt
people in there in the first place and
it almost makes me think of um when i
had astra taylor on the podcast quite a
while back uh i had never heard about
sortition before this idea of uh making
choices for a national government by
picking random citizens and having them
really think about it and the good news
is that you know in the cases where it
has been tried it actually works pretty
well like the outcomes are you know ones
that people generally agree with and you
know that's sort of an extreme example
of how to avoid this problem that it's
uh um more than an average number of
psychopaths want to be in these
positions of power
yeah i have in in the in the last third
of the book i have these like 10
solutions and one of them is sortition
for oversight it's not sortician itself
it's sortition with a twist because uh
you know and for people who are
unfamiliar with this the the ancient
greeks uh in some instances used this
thing called the claritarian to
effectively create random jury duty for
citizen government and you know they
suggested it worked reasonably well
my problem with it in 2022 is that some
of the aspects of being a politician
require specialist knowledge sure if you
negotiate a nuclear test ban treaty you
had better understand aspects of state
craft and diplomacy and nuclear weapons
that the average person probably doesn't
but what i do think we should do with
sortition is create effectively
oversight bodies um that provide
accountability so my proposal both for
businesses and for politics is to create
like a shadow house of representatives
or a shadow board in a company that is
totally randomly selected that debates
exactly the same things that has exactly
the same access to experts and
information as the actual people and
then produces pronouncements or
decisions that are non-binding and the
reason you do this is because
if you are having the house of
representatives make a decision either
due to partisanship or lobbying or
re-election
a lot of those effects would be
neutralized as would the self-selection
effect by the random sortition shadow
house of representatives now it wouldn't
change anything that could still do it
but it would be quite a cudgel in terms
of rhetorical challenging to these
groups to say you know a journalist in
an interview saying
when we randomly selected a group of
americans they had a different view of
this you know they did something quite
different why was that you know when
they thought about an infrastructure
bill it didn't take them six years to
figure it out they just sort of hashed
out the details and came up with
something why couldn't you do that and i
think it's that sort of thing where
the same would be true for a business
you could say you know wait a minute you
seem to have this myopic profit motive
uh in the board of directors of the
company why not uh look at what the
employees are saying the random
selection of employees that's quite
divergent from what you're proposing and
there are shadow boards by the way in
some german companies um they're just
not randomly selected so they have like
a shadow board of employees which does
provide some of the help but because
it's not randomized it's people who are
also trying to get ahead and that you
know i think that's why i think
randomization for uh for this oversight
body would would be a good thing you
know i'm sure that this is a wild pie in
the sky thing but i kind of like the
idea of just adding a whole new
chamber to the u.s congress so there are
three of them and one of them is
completely sortationed and if any two of
the three can agree on some legislation
to get sent up to the president i think
you know that there are crazier things
we could try
well there's also i mean the thing is
like i know this sounds it's one of
those ideas where i'm like thinking
about this while i'm writing the book
and i'm like yeah this probably will
never happen but it's actually one of
the ones that's the easiest to make it
happen because you don't have to be
official in other words some billionaire
could just say i'm gonna set up a
shadowhouse of representatives i'm gonna
pay 435 random people a year's salary
the same as a congress person's salary
which they would jump at because it's
writ you know you get rich on this
and i'm gonna have them do this and i'm
gonna use it as a as a way to sort of
hold politicians accountable now you'd
have to have journalists pay attention
to it you'd have to make it sort of
matter in a certain way but it wouldn't
require anything legal because
the power of it is not legally binding
the power of it is showing the
divergence between how politicians
behave and how the rest of us would
behave in the same situation and i think
that's the
the the magic of it so to speak the same
is true by the way for like awarding
contracts like if you're awarding
contracts based on lobbyists and you ask
the shadow house of representatives or a
shadow
white house or whatever to do the same
job
they wouldn't do it based on who's
greasing the wheels and it would be
quite informative for people to say wait
a minute maybe we should look at this a
second time because there's such a
massive disconnect between
this group of unelected citizens that
are just sort of a parallel body funded
by some
benevolent person in society um but you
know i think i think it could actually
provide some some crucial checks on on
people in power no i do like that my my
uh plan was entirely uh fantasyland but
yours is quasi-realistic i could imagine
something like that happening that's
interesting to contemplate and you
mentioned something very quickly um that
i wanted to ask earlier but let's just
emphasize it we've been talking about
politics in government but you said also
you know corporations boards presumably
universities local organizations
whatever the all all this discourse that
we've had about corruption is it is it
more or less the same discourse in every
organization or is there something
special about politics
no i think that there are i think that
the dynamics that exist in other
organizations are basically on steroids
and politics because it
in most systems not all of them but in
most systems money and power are twinned
and so it doesn't just have the one or
the other it has both um but i think you
know one of the things i talk about in
the book that's going to be more
familiar to to listeners
is
the idea of these sort of dynamics
closer to home and i have one intro to
the chat each chapter sort of starts off
with this interesting vignette so to
speak um and and one of them is a
homeowner's association a tyrant who is
just utterly obsessed with power and
doing things that are quite absurd where
he's you know writing up his neighbors
for having the wrong kind of gravel or
their palm tree hasn't been trimmed in
the requisite 24-day period or whatever
it is and
it's such a recognizable pathology for
most of us that we know someone like
this oh yeah who just loves the power it
gets off on the power so i i don't think
it's unique to these certain
organizations i think there is a
universality to this um what i do think
is that some organizations think about
it more and those organizations tend to
avoid the problems more often i mean
my my my dream with this book which you
know it's the naive author dream uh and
i'm sure for for for your work you you
hope that people who have never come
across you know quantum physics ideas
will discuss them and it will profoundly
change their world view my my my dream
is uh with this one is that powerful
people in some of these organizations
will
think carefully about how they
design systems around power
and imagine
that their system has to exist to
prevent
the worst person who is trying to scheme
to get in
into a position of power at every level
so they design a system that deters the
bad people that constrains them when
they get power and finds a way to boot
them out when they actually stay for too
long and so on and just designs a system
with that in mind not because we have to
be distrustful of our fellow citizen but
because those people exist and we'd be
better off if the system was designed to
counteract those people right and and i
think you know it's it's something where
i don't know whether this will ever
happen i'd love to get an email at some
point where some police chief in like
louisiana says i read your book and now
we recruit differently but um
it's it's the sort of idea is that
it doesn't take massive massive changes
to make things better it takes it takes
around the edges of forums that can dial
down uh some of these human tendencies
uh around power
yeah no i mean i i completely agree it's
nice to think that you could have some
even minor real world tangible effects
and the local
areas are probably where you could
actually have pretty big effects but but
also this is a great segue into i really
wanted to sort of wind up with these
programmatic things we can do
to prevent the people who would be
susceptible to becoming corrupt from
actually carrying it out but
on a rather uh detached angle i wanted
to start with the insects that you talk
about uh you know we're getting uh hints
from other sorts of species and what
they do and unlike that you know with
the primates
we think it's pretty close so we can
relate to them the insects are very very
different than us and their social
structures are very different than us
but you can see the game theory at work
and so tell me how insects uh
sort of scheme to prevent
free-riding insects from becoming queen
or whatever it is that they want to try
to do
yeah this is a fun bit of research it's
about bees and wasps and
the ways in which the systems in which
their hives function across species
affects what i call corruption i think
probably a biologist would take issue
with this but i'm trying to get at the
point of of sort of
anti-hive behavior in other words
behavior that is non-adaptive for the
hive as a whole but might be adaptive
for the individual and uh and
effectively you have these different
species that are quite similar but with
key uh divergences one of them
is how the hive is designed so in some
species the hive is designed in a way
that is more or less transparent in
other words you you don't have sort of a
cap over the larva so you can see what's
developing in each sort of little
capsule i might be getting some of these
details wrong
but but the the gist of it is that you
can see uh into the area where the larva
has been deposited so it's literal
transparency
yes there's there's transparency exactly
exactly so there's there's this this is
like transparency for which you can see
if someone's trying to basically make a
queen or is trying to make a worker and
the problem is it might be adaptive for
some excess queens to exist for the
individual because this is you know this
is the way you replicate your genetic
code and so on uh but excess queens
can't exist in the hive you have to kill
them so there's only one queen per hive
and they have what are called by the
biologists uh police bees that go around
to inspect uh if there are any excess
queens in the making and if they are uh
discovered they're they're killed
they're brutally beheaded basically um
and what's fascinating is in the
difference between the hive structure
the transparent versus the
non-transparent cells
have very different uh levels of
shirking or free rioting in this
instance because the police bees
or police wasps in this case are
ineffectual they can't tell very well
and it's also about the size so in some
of the hives the size of the cell for
the queen is much bigger than the size
of the
size of the cell for the worker and that
also makes the inspection much much
easier because you're not just looking
at all of them at the same time you can
gravitate towards the cells that are big
and see if there's excess excess queens
it's just it's a nice little way of
showing how much structure affects uh
levels of of what could be deemed in the
human world to be corruption although
i haven't gotten any emails yet from
angry wasp specialists saying i'm uh
anthropomorphizing uh insects to an
extreme degree but i probably am so
there you go
and so what do we learn from this i mean
uh does it work differently for
different kinds of insects uh is there a
right level of police bee surveillance
that we need to have to stem the
corruption without being too
authoritarian well i think i think the
the the the lesson from it is that it
does matter if you have transparency and
accountability that is made more easy um
and you know i write in the sort of last
part of the book about surveillance
systems and how
the more i pondered this the more i was
confused about why we sort of tolerated
the system in which the most surveilled
or the least powerful yeah because you
know you think about all the corporate
scandals the political scandals the
things that actually have created
profound and disastrous consequences
they're happening at the top right and
and the pandemic has created this new
sort of dystopian level of surveillance
for work from home people where like
some companies in the u.s now have
installed chair sensors to figure out
whether you're actually sitting on your
chair when you claim to be um and
they're trying to make sure you don't
take you know an extra 10 minute lunch
break
it's like you know enron didn't get
brought down by lunch breaks being too
long it was this this was the corner
offices where the surveillance is
deliberately avoided
and so you know my view is that power
should be a burden in some ways and
therefore it should come with scrutiny
attached to it and people should really
worry when they behave badly in
positions of immense power that they
will get caught um so i think that the
surveillance systems that we've designed
in the sort of corporate workplace they
do as you speak you know when you asked
about the insects there is sort of a
goldilocks solution to this which is you
don't want a workplace in which you feel
constantly distrustful of everyone you
know you don't want to like bait the
break room fridge and see who steals the
sandwich or something like that but you
do want to have a level of second
guessing for people making
really corrupt decisions or abusive
decisions and management such that they
think they're going to get caught and
that's the the police wasp example is to
say
why have we designed a system in which
we've effectively said there is no
transparency in the cells of management
there is transparency only in the cells
of the worker bees and the worker bees
in the analogy of course with the
ordinary employees taking the extra long
coffee break
yeah and of course it's going to be very
different in uh countries or societies
that have long struggled with corruption
and like the examples you said earlier
where there's a coup every so often and
it's very dangerous but in a you know
grown-up democratic arrangement i'm kind
of shocked that we or maybe i'm not
shocked but depressed that we don't make
it harder for politicians to benefit off
of their positions you know i would go
so far as to say that if you really
wanted to run for office i would love to
see if you had to give up some of your
wealth right like rather because not
only do we make it possible for you to
manipulate things once you're in office
so that your wealth grows but it's hard
to run for office unless you're already
very very wealthy and that's just a
connection that seems wrong to me
i i agree completely i mean stock
trading is the obvious example in
western democracies that debate now is
existing in the u.s a bit
but it's it's absurd i mean the amount
of money
if you just look at how people get much
richer in their time in congress that
shouldn't exist yeah but i also think
you know
i think we have to think outside the box
a little bit on this i think that people
should worry that they're going to get
caught i have a a bit in the book where
i talk about sting operations in the
nypd where they do these integrity tests
and basically test cops
in these fake crime scenes that they
think are real and the really profound
insight of it was that they did 500
integrity tests where they you know they
come in and there's cash on the table
and they see if they steal it or
whatever and they fire them or arrest
them if they do um
but they did 500 of these tests when
they surveyed the police uh 12 000
police officers said yes i have been
subject to an integrity test so 11 500
had real crime scenes that they thought
were fake and behaved better as a result
of it and then the rest of the police
thought that every time they walked into
a crime scene it could be fake so the
the obvious question is why don't we set
up sting operations for politicians more
often like why don't we set up systems
where you know a contract is being
awarded and there's an elaborate sort of
uh attempt to make a fake company that
pays all the right lobbyists and gives
kickbacks and catches the politicians
who ensure that that company gets a
contract i mean you know these are the
kinds of things where
it requires a paradigm shift of saying
you know what like there are things that
you have to accept that you might not
like for being in power but that is the
responsibility of the position and it's
the same for the police right i mean
there's there's instances where yes okay
if you do stings in your standard
company like in your hr department it's
not a great world to live in uh and and
i don't want to have that but the police
are in a unique position where their
abusive behavior when it happens is so
destructive that they should be
put in these positions and so you know
my view is that the the positions of
power that are the most prone to abuse
are the ones that should be most
surveilled and very often uh they're the
ones that are least surveilled
unfortunately
i know i think that makes sense and i
especially like the idea that you know
you should be willing to give up on some
things if you are going to serve in
these positions i mean
politicians love to refer to their time
in public service as if they're really
giving up everything they wanted but
they campaigned for it they really
wanted to do it so i i'm not
giving them credit for humility getting
there but there's one question that
comes to mind when you talk about the
you know the companies or the the um
sting operations or whatever which is
that
that seems like the most blatant kind of
corruption that we're targeting there
isn't a bigger worry the softer kinds of
corruption where people are just
voting or or signing bills based more on
what their donors want them to do than
what would be good for the country or
even what their constituents would like
them to do
yeah i mean absolutely i i think it's
they're not mutually exclusive i think
you know i i have these like these 10
examples that i talk about in the at the
end of the book
they're they're as i say they're not
silver bullets um they're all things
that would slightly help uh if done in
tandem and none of them solve every
problem right so as i said before
there's one of the examples that i talk
about of of you know creating visceral
reminders of the weight of
responsibility of power
for a lot of normal people that actually
could help it will make them feel bad
about hurting other people for
psychopaths will be totally useless so
you can
but but i do think that with this sort
of more run-of-the-mill corruption this
is where things like sortition could
help with with oversight where you're
exposing the motivations but also one
thing we haven't talked about is why do
we accept self-selection yeah why do we
say that the people who are in charge of
us are the people who put themselves
forward to be in charge of us why don't
we proactively recruit more i mean
political parties should be spending a
lot more money as your organizations of
seeking out people with track records of
integrity and service genuine service
not serving themselves and saying you
should be in power and we're going to
try to make it attractive for you to be
in power and you know again it's it's
one of these things where yes it's sort
of pie in the sky thinking it's a little
bit of a broad brush but it is it's not
happening at all like even even if we
did 10 more of this it would be
worthwhile um because what you usually
see in political backgrounds is like
somebody makes a lot of money and then
they have a vanity project which is i'll
become a politician and i'll cement my
legacy after i've made millions of
dollars in business or whatever and you
know you don't have these people who are
like
they serve the community they're
exceptional individuals they're clearly
full of integrity let's really head hunt
them uh and and i wish that there was a
lot more of that sort of drafting
mentality of people in power a lot of
them would say no i mean a lot of these
people would not accept it sure but
you'd get more of them and
this is the thing as i say i feel like
i'm like banging my head against the
wall as i watch the world unfold in all
these sort of horrible ways is like
this isn't
it's it's not written in stone that it
has to be this way
there's not going to be a world that's a
utopia i'm not some naive idealist but
you can blunt a lot of these things with
careful interventions and systemic
reform and
we don't talk about it and the news also
i mean you know i'm a participant in the
news because i write for the washington
post and so on but like the news is
uniquely bad at talking about systemic
reform it's very very good at talking
about the outrage of the day so all of
the attention is like why does the
current crop of powerful people behave
badly and it's caused us to zoom in on
such a tiny subset of the real problem
which is if you zoom out it's like the
current subset of people in power are
not the right subset of people in power
and the who question is just totally
taken out right and instead it's the
what they do question that we focus on
and that that i think is the the big
thing that i hope people take away uh
from the book and from my research
i guess one question i mean i like the
idea it sounds good one question is
about who would have the incentive to
set up things like this you know who's
incentivized to try to get more selfless
people into government i mean the people
who presumably are supposed to be doing
this are the ones who are already in
government so there's kind of a chicken
and egg problem this is like the totally
dystopian answer that i have to give
based on u.s politics is probably some
billionaire yeah because like you know
we have a system that's so broken that
the only people that can basically wield
power above the politicians are probably
the people with very very deep pockets
right so you need some pro-social very
rich person which you know itself is
like such a damning indictment of our
system like the reform will come from
the person who's already super rich i
think it's just but i i think that's the
only most realistic answer um
you're right i mean it's asking you know
the the foxes
to basically you know police themselves
in the hen house and it's not going to
happen uh but
you know
again it's one of those things where you
work on social research you're like i'm
going to try to put my best answers
forward and i hope that some people
will listen to them and i hope that the
people who don't actually cause the
change start thinking this way and you
hope it has a sort of domino effect i
mean you know
any any exercise in trying to write a
book about how we can make a better
world based on corrupt powerful people
does run into this inevitable problem
that corrupt powerful people are the
ones who make the rules um but you know
it's still a worthwhile endeavor because
i think you can get closer to to a
better world than we have now yeah no i
i look i work on theoretical physics i
mean i cannot complain that other people
are doing unrealistic things i'm trying
to think about where the universe came
from but speaking of unrealistic things
one last thing that i wanted to ask you
about um
let's home in on this idea that we
should sort of recruit better people
that kind of begs the question of do we
know who the better people are right i
mean maybe yes we want people who are
not completely psychopaths or motivated
by uh greed or or power but
at some point you seem to be suggesting
that there could be you know
hyper-competent people who are just too
introverted to run for office or
whatever and it made me wonder
would such people actually be good at
the job of being a politician i mean
there is some overlap between the skill
set that gets you elected in the skill
set that makes you effective once you're
in office over and above technocratic
competence
yeah i mean i think that's true right i
think that there are some people who are
very extroverted charming individuals
who can build coalitions in politics
that can get stuff done uh and that's
absolutely the case but i do think that
we have to have a higher bar for
political leaders right and it's not
it's not just politicians it's also uh
people in in positions of power and
other parts of life so
first off the thing you'd say is you
want a track record so you'd want
somebody who has proven public service
in a different realm of their life
outside of politics and perhaps someone
who has shown integrity
those people would be top of my list for
head hunting for a political party the
other thing i think that's that's an
oddity about you know if you sort of
again you sort of just look at our
system and say
well does it always have to be this way
is
we have like no requirements whatsoever
to be president i mean
and for congress too i mean i i said i
said this sort of tongue-in-cheek in one
of the interviews i did about the book
but i mean it's true is i'm i'm a total
history nerd so i'm training to be a
tour guide at a cathedral where i live
in in england and i have six months of
training it's two and a half hours a
week two different tests one written one
verbal and i'm like this is much more
robust training and oversight than like
any politician ever goes through other
than the election where they just have
to make people like them and you know i
know these things are sort of naive so i
thought i thought how could we actually
do this because you're not going to get
most politicians to submit to a
psychopath test but one way you could do
it is the ones who are quite confident
that they're not psychopaths would start
to voluntarily do it and it would put
pressure on the other ones because the
voters would then have a shortcut like
why aren't they doing the psychometric
test and some businesses by the way do
do psychometric tests and evaluations
for their sort of elite team
the other thing that i think about is
you know why don't we have a situation
occasionally where these presidential
candidates like go to the new york times
for their their interview that they all
do and they have the write-up and all
this stuff
why don't they ever get like uh
surprised by the fact the new york times
on the interviews says oh by the way
we're going to give you a test
and you don't have to do it but we're
going to publish whether you agree to it
or not and the questions are basic
things that you should know if you're
president you know what is the defense
budget and i think it would be really
really useful because i think you're
right that there are some skills that do
overlap between campaigning and
governing but they're not perfectly
correlated by any means and i think the
knowledge
aspect of governing has been decreased
so much where you don't have to know
anything i mean you know
without getting too political here the
last five years six years in u.s
politics has been a pretty profound
education that you can let know like
literally nothing about the way the
government works and still be president
i mean i i was banging my head against
the wall as well when i was teaching
students about nato and they kept saying
like
trump keeps talking about how like
they're not paying into the fund and i'm
like there is no fund like
they've pledged two percent of their
national you know budgets to defense
spending this is different from a fund
and yet you know it's 2020 and he's
still talking about how they need to pay
into the fund so you have you have
aspects of
political life for which there are no
barriers and it's not to say that we
should you know subject people to
something extreme but like let's have
something like this let's think maybe
you should be qualified for this job
where a cathedral tour guide is not
actually a more rigorous training
process than being the prime minister or
president of the country
well you know i always like when
possible it's not always possible to end
on an upbeat note and now you've given
me um the thought experiment that every
politician would be given a test to see
how psychopathic they are and the
results would be made publicly available
so i don't think it's gonna happen but
i'm just gonna go with that uh fantasy
in my mind for a little while so brian
kloss thanks so much for being on the
windscape podcast
thanks so it's been brilliant to talk to
you
[Music]